Preston fons morning routine usually
starts here in the storage facility
Hayden this is all my gear yeah kind of
like my own headquarters I guess change
of shoes or your laundry this is a
blanket and pillow I hope to use that in
the future when I do get my own place
he's harmless but that hasn't stopped
him from pursuing his dream job
in the tech industry any given day I
don't really know where I'm gonna be
sleeping so it makes it really difficult
to plan for the next day if you want to
succeed
Preston already has some coding skills
but he needs a network so he joined code
tenderloin a job training program for
disadvantaged students so the population
we serve are folks that are homeless
folks who are formerly incarcerated
folks who lack transportation people who
don't believe they fit into tech the
program was started in the Tenderloin
San Francisco neighborhood that's been
synonymous with code read despair for
decades until five years ago when the
city started offering companies tax
breaks to lure them into the
neighborhood but even with some of the
biggest tech companies now in the area
the homelessness and poverty remain
Jennifer keishon brings about displaced
me evictions cheering bhakta is an
affordable housing advocate who grew up
in the Tenderloin the Tenderloin is
perhaps the only neighborhood left in
San Francisco for low-income
working-class people to find a home so
right now the Tenderloin is going
through the first steps of
gentrification and turning into a
neighborhood of haves and have-nots
instead of fighting the change some
community-based organizations like code
tenderloin and glide memorial church are
working to make sure impoverished
residents also benefit
as Co Tenderloin creates a platform for
allowing people who are part of the
Tenderloin to engage in this new economy
you know when you have someone show up
with a different vantage point that's
the secret sauce for innovation in
addition to hard skills like coding they
help students Croft resumes practice job
interviews and network with tech
employees we realize these are early
days in the program but like every
community outreach effort has to start
somewhere and we're building the
relationship and we're providing access
to the Twitter engineers as part of an
ongoing project that we really want to
improve over time but code tenderloin
can't guarantee employment around 90
students have gone through the program
and only a handful have landed jobs in
tech we're not asking tech to take
someone who's unqualified or who lacks
talent we're not asking for a handout
we're not asking for a favor we're
asking for access we're asking for
opportunity companies have promised to
be good neighbors to the Tenderloin have
promised to provide an influx of capital
into the neighborhood and to help the
job training all that stuff sounds good
on paper
however after so many years of the tech
industry being in San Francisco have we
actually seen real improvements for the
working class and low-income people in
the neighborhood I think that question
is yet to be answered Preston's a little
more hopeful I just graduated from Co
tenderloin I have applied for the reach
program at LinkedIn and hopefully I'll
get into that program and start working
as a developer I think I do have a good
chance and I think I should be given an
opportunity just to prove myself in the
tech industry
you